the berlin boro of nikon is the
heartland of the city's turkish
community most Turks living here voted
in the election on the weekend there's
strong support for red ship Toyota ones
a Kay party on these streets the oil
engine they look towards the west and
really brought the country forward the
political developments weren't bad
either
I'm really upset about it about the AKP
losing yes that they're no longer what
they once were in my opinion they
provide stability for Turkey and that's
good for our country but not everyone
agrees
there's no love lost between the AKP and
the Turkish Kurds for example but in
this Kurdish cultural center there's
also little enthusiasm for the left-wing
HDB party leaders themselves have said
the HDP is not a pro-kurdish party but
in principle we're happy that they're in
Parliament and that the AKP is weaker
you get the impression that era Diwan
wanted to rule alone frankly and that
doesn't sound good to me so I'm happy
that he hasn't been able to reach his
goal
they shut Kurdish parents want their
children to one day have the opportunity
to live in a better Turkey many hope
this election result will be a step in
that direction